llegó a la política nacional al ser
elegido congresista con el partido de
centroderecha acción popular como
presidente del congreso manuel merino
encabezó en los dos juicios políticos
contra el entonces mandatario martín
vizcarra quien fue destituido en el
último debate por acusaciones de
sobornos
de hoop a las del gobierno
su reemplazo fue merino de 59 años pues
la segunda vicepresidenta que seguía en
la línea de mando del ejecutivo renunció
hace una miles de peruanos se volcaron a
las calles en contra del nuevo gobierno
de transición para muchos el de merino
es un gobierno ilegítimo que representa
a los partidos tradicionales y que se
oponen a las ideas de vizcarra la lucha
anti corrupción y una reforma
universitaria las encuestas favorecen
además al exmandatario
se han atrevido a bajar a una persona
con esta aceptación en un momento
terrible para nuestro país es tener
responsabilidad realmente demuestran que
les importa nada y ahora tenemos que
estar muy atentos de todo lo que pueda
pasar más adelante con este congreso que
realmente es terrible merino siguió
adelante a pesar del rechazo nombró al
conservador ántero flores-aráoz como su
jefe de ministros y completó el gabinete
con funcionarios más tradicionales y
pocas mujeres incluidas lo hacemos un
llamado a la calma y a la
responsabilidad para que cualquier
expresión política
esté dada dentro del ámbito de la
tranquilidad sus decisiones
convulsionaron aún más al país el jueves
pero vivió las protestas más grandes en
20 años la onu y amnistía internacional
denunciaron la brutalidad policial pero
la violencia sólo escaló en las marchas
del sábado dos jóvenes murieron y hubo
más de 90 heridos
merino desconoce las razones de las
protestas y dice que los peruanos salen
a las calles cansados del desempleo y
del aislamiento por la pandemia
[Música]